right around the time that we met you
know I was getting ready to go fight and
that was the first time I ever met
Poirier because Poirier was cornering a
guy who was on the same card and I just
went straight in Connecticut it was in
Connecticut
something yeah he just he got a couple
wins in a row yeah he's good Emporia was
there over the whole five-week corner
and whatnot and I just went straight up
to him because I I knew at this point I
was probably gonna go I was probably
going to leave Bellator uh and I was
probably gonna hopefully sign with the
UFC my goal was I wanted to sign with
UFC so I knew I was about to walk up to
a guy that was probably gonna I'm gonna
be the same division for sure I'm
probably gonna end up fighting him but
to me the respect level for a guy like
Poirier or even anybody in the division
I don't
I respect you if you step inside the
cage you make your living doing what I
do doing what we do because this is what
was it I understand the perils the
trials the tribulations of this this
tough sport that we call our our
profession but went up to him and we're
talking a little bit and I just you know
I congratulated on on his last win he
had just beaten Dan hooker a couple
weeks prior
congratulations on the fight of the Year
candidate that it was it was a
phenomenal fight his heart his
determination what he does outside the
cage the man that he is the competitor
that he is the father that he is and
then also we kind of talked like
about the journey a little bit where
it's like man 30 something years old now
got a wife got a kid got it you know
doing what we're doing is much different
than back in the day I kind of brought
up how he was some young shaved head
Punk kid on that documentary you saw
that oh yeah his documentary alone and
that was Dustin Poirier from back in the
day and he was in this documentary crazy
this is an insane thing coming out of
the swamp exactly and but it's so cool
to see where people start
and then where people end up and then
and watch every and watch people's
maturation throughout the journey and
and he he would probably if he was
sitting here today he would probably say
man you know his his career I think is a
blueprint for a guy who who started at a
certain point has ended up where he's at
he's at the top of the game top of the
division top of the toughest division in
the in the entire world about to fight
the biggest Global Superstar of of mixed
martial arts and Conor McGregor he's in
a phenomenal spot but you don't just
fall there by accident you don't fall to
the top of the mountain
by just by coincidence you know he had
to build and climb and plod and and
tread towards that and a lot of it comes
with good things happen to good people
you know and it's not though it's not
that people don't do the right things
it's that people don't do the right
things for long enough and he's put his
time in
grown into a phenomenal man father
husband and yeah he's going to be a good
role model so it's cool just just seeing
the maturation process of of us as
Fighters you know yeah a decade later